what is a narrative snapshot movie
actually it's a strategy on how to write
and see a lot of times writers think
that everything come out come out right
the first time
well that's no you need to tweak and
tweak and tweak between and one other
thing is just the snapshot movie
exercise and I actually took this
exercise Dan and used it in teaching
writing and what how I do that is I have
the students look in a picture this
picture's worth a thousand words
make this picture a movie so what I do
is I have them work through the five
senses it's just a paragraph and it's
really hard to do because it's very
concise so how does it taste how does it
feel how does it smell
and and you walk through it and so this
paragraph of this picture has to become
a movie and so my whole book is I call
them scenes because they're moving
scenes and I picture everything as if it
if you were watching it as a director
creates a movie a writer creates the
book it's the same process but use words
instead of pictures and actors students
let's say you have a photo of a man
talking to a woman one student might
interpret it as he's professing his love
to her another one would say he's
breaking up with her they kind of they
interpret what but see they have to go
deeper than that what in that picture
makes you think he's bringing up with
her the way he's standing
space his eyes his hand by language what
makes you think that so it's just not
the global thought it's the details and
again I have my own little thoughts on
things but I believe the details in the
history and the characters make the
difference between a good book and a
great book because the details evoke the
emotion and the emotion makes you
connect with the story and if the
details aren't there it's just a one of
those I hate to say this romance novels
that was a very popular and many like to
read my girlfriend loves romance novels
she had a hard time reading mine yeah
she it didn't really interest her
because it was through detail too much
information she didn't like we said she
says good story good story men and women
would always like yeah you don't want to
like it but she did it you know she just
I just like mine romance novels and and
there's a niche for them and that's fine
this he Minds historical genre so you
kind of fiction you know so it's a
different niche you've got to like the
niche well for me like I love Judy Blume
oh yeah
I never liked the the teen the Sweet
Valley High whatever and that's not to
not think but but I like Judy Blume
actually put a lot of detail and her
stuff and she also touched on topics
that most of us didn't but or somebody
like an ally Goldberg and she puts a lot
of detail and what she writes so do you
think that some people can't handle that
I think that's too much it's it's not
that they can't handle it they just
don't care for it I see yeah it's like
my friend she just I want something just
like I just want something I can just
get through I don't want all that detail
I wear have to think you know and
there's a and that's okay it's like when
I was a principal at a private school in
Palm Beach I had to be so tired from it
and the to show pepper on I hope I don't
offend anybody but the two shows are on
when I came home or Hercules and Xena
the warrior princess and I could just
sit there it sit back and just not think
about anything and just watch so you
know it was needed at that time in my
life nothing real heavy but of interest
to me I kind of liked it you know and so
it's like different readers that's why
we have so different many books and so
many different successful authors
because maybe it's not you know what did
I like to read before I just didn't read
like stuff like that but I'm an
education and a professor you know so my
brain has been kind of skewed to other
things
you